[Musik]
hallo herr namens alice wäre heute gibt
einlädt lecker.de mittagsgericht und
zwar mache ich eine bunte gemüsepfanne
ich liebe ja nudel rezepte aber ich
liebe auch ein free press bei mir oder
bei uns ganz auf türkischen reis als
beilage aras welten machen wir mal so
eine bunte gemüse reispfanne die kriegen
gibt die heute ich hab heute morgen ganz
früh timo rath vom klo gut einkaufen
geschickt ganzen fundus gemüse gekauft
und habe geschimpft weil es sehr viel
ist aber in konkret die luft nur
grundzutaten die man immer im
kühlschrank haben soll
viele leckere gemüse sorten wenn ihr
möchtet könnt ihr dann natürlich auch
fleisch oder fisch meeresfrüchte zufügen
dann erinnerte fans von kristen an das
spanische paar er aber das hier ist kein
original rezept für mehr lohne
leichter abwandlung und ich zeige euch
mal die flut hatten dafür brauche es
löffel olivenöl eine rote und gelbe
paprika eine band bloc male eine chance
wales kaum chancen bei 100 gramm dubai
erbten oder zucker wohnen hier habe ich
noch jeweils einen teelöffel paprika und
kurkuma einen teneriffa 300 gramm
naturreis oder so was du für welches
level 3 400 gramm cocktailtomaten eine
unbehandelte zitrone 1 bund petersilie
salz pfeffer und hier habe ich noch
etwas gutes ich werde zuerst einmal also
das gemüse habe ich jetzt schon
geschehen teilweise aus wie charlotte
den rest gewachsen und die werden fein
hacken
murat i fakty wahrscheinlich warum hat
er den geschehens abgestimmt weil er
einfach mit manchen gemüse sport nichts
anfangen konnte die fans zum beispiel
gab es bei ihm zu hause ist aber nur für
echte zu sagen können ich werde gesund
und man sollte ganz offen
vor allem weil es eben auch krämpfe im
bauch zum beispiel löst und man kennt
hier auf unser baby vier oder fünf liter
punkten mehr auf den fersen anis kümmel
film und das macht eben die
bauchschmerzen weg und auch so als salat
zu verlängern
[Musik]
die stadt laufen habe ich jetzt freien
gewürfelt
da wusste er auch erstmal liegt macht
verlockende gedacht von ihrer freundin
die charlotte nein das sind triebel und
zwar sind die besonders milden geschmack
zuerst einmal das olivenöl in einer
pfanne oder in einem großen topf da die
mich jetzt die zweite weil ich einfach
schön drin rühren kann das hat mit ganz
große fläche da kommen jetzt die
schalotten rein und werden bei mittlerer
stufe angeboten und ich kann mich schon
mal um restliche gemüse kümmern
zuerst einmal die paprika da ist es ganz
gut wenn ihr hier oben den strom kein
bisschen eindruck wo habt ihr am
wenigsten abfall dann schneide ich darin
photonik und einfach wie viele seiten
schön runter
[Musik]
die wird gewürfelt
mängel
weiter gibt mit der fan technology wird
halbiert
wahrscheinlich da unten den schmuck ab
und reggae und auf die jungs
einschneiden
[Musik]
du bist du
borken
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich das gemüse mit den laptop
gemeinsam mit den gewürzen paprika und
kurkuma
[Musik]
jetzt erhöhten bis in die temperatur und
lasse boesen bisschen anbraten und in
der zeit kann es auch schon mal die
zuckererbsen und die tomaten schneiden
[Musik]
die zuckererbsen leben mit dazu denn
auch kurz durch gerührt und dann ist
auch schon der reisende reihen hat die
von wilfried so schön weil er dieses
schwarzen bereits kann er noch mit drin
hat aber ihr könnt ihr jeden anderen
reisen auch in vorleistung beispiel wenn
es auch super lecker und vor allem
gesund und das ganze lässt sich jetzt
mit gemüse früher ab
nämlich jetzt noch nicht alle last auf
kochen und je nach sorte müsst jetzt
einfach mal bleibt auf der verpackung
schauen ob der nur 82 minuten gearbeitet
hat oder auch 30 minuten unterscheidet
ist einfach nach der sorte mit lassen
aufkochen und dann bei mittlerer stufe
mit deckel durchsehen und an der stelle
gehen wird auf schloss passen
[Musik]
meine leiste an der luft liegt mir und
kochen dann habe ich noch 20 minuten den
heraus gemacht
zwischendurch immer mal wieder gerührt
und dann sieht man auch schon wieder
aufgeht und die flüssigkeit aufsaugt und
jetzt habe ich ihnen noch mal mit
geschlossenem deckel fünf minuten
einfach stehenlassen zum queren die auch
das richtig schön locker und wie gesagt
je nach worten frau unterschrieben
ich gebe ich sehe jetzt noch ein
bisschen zitronenschale drüber daher
eine unbehandelte zitrone macht das
ganze so
und dann hätte ich den sachverhalt wird
ohne mit je nach geschmack auch der die
ganze zu tun
[Musik]
tomaten noch mit rein
die kommen zum schluss dass er einfach
nicht so verkommen und hebe ich mir für
die politiker auf jetzt wo ich das noch
mal kurz und kam zu einem konflikt und
servieren wir das licht petersilie und
mit dem flug seien
[Musik]
ich habe bereits planiert immer richtig
schön teller angerichtet
da kommen jetzt noch zitrone und mit
petersilie und für flaubert und ich zeig
euch jetzt noch wie ich trainieren wird
auch das haupt vermutlich wenig kaputt
machen hier einen fleck den bereich dazu
ein klecks joghurt oder schmand habe ich
ein bisschen zitronenschalen abwickler
zugegeben eine scheibe zitrone tomaten
und da wegen der mac haben wir gesagt
noch fenster grünen nehmen ist auch toll
zum glück gut machen
würde alles probieren wir ohne den
joghurt ohne den jüdisches ganze
übrigens auch komplett veganen
[Musik]
suva fresh stärker als ihre platten
machen wollt dann geht auch wenn ich -
lockt er steht man ganz genau für euch
und ich finde ich ein richtig leckeres
rezept vor allem kanada ganz viel gemüse
mit einpacken auch minister mohammed
immer mag aber diese frau zepp jedoch
eher mögen weg gleich nach hause
er ist gab noch mal kurz weg gefahren
und dann war für das ausprobieren also
viel spaß beim name hand und bis zum
nächsten mal
dr
[Musik]